como se llegó a tal situación de tensión
y distanciamiento de tres francia y malí
buenas noches
sí mira ha habido un golpe de otro un
golpe dos golpes en menos de un año el
primero en agosto de 2020 y el segundo
en mayo año pasado a partir de ahí la
relación con francia comenzaron a
estropearse y la junta de transición
militar estaba anunciando en principio
que iba a haber una salida electoral
en toda la democracia en este febrero y
el grupo militar así milita y compañía
en torno a la página
tras 25 años de transición lo cual en
largo varios actores reconoció las
sanciones contra más mal y de frase de
auge en la comunidad estados de áfrica
cinta desde económica y eso ha detonado
la ola de la crisis final cuando el 31
especial después ahora a las críticas
francesas
para macos respondió la junta que
respondió con el ultimátum de 72 horas
dispuesto el 21 de enero pasado para la
expulsión del embajador
francés en el media en mamá con lo cual
se cumplió a partir de ahí hay un
reconocimiento un distanciamiento
efectivo que augura digamos el abandono
inminente que se podría decir mañana en
un evento paralelo a la cumbre unión
africana-unión europea pero también no
es solamente una descompresión de la
presencia francesa sino también de otros
y de otras misiones que están europeos
ahora a ver qué significaría para la
lucha contra el yihadismo este repliegue
francés en mali
para mal y sería muy complicado porque
también hay una
diferencia entre la junta y francia
mismo sobre el proceder con respecto a
los grupos yihadistas francia es más
partidaria de no negociar de atacar de
hacer el planteo militar y eventualmente
la junta plantea cierta cierta
negociación cierto diálogo y esto esto
podría provocar la relocalización no el
abandono completo del sahel sino de malí
y la reubicación de la misión marcan la
misión tacuba que la misión europea
también la cual francia tiene un peso
importante pero justamente se dispuso la
disminución del efectivo francés para
aumentar un poco en la proporción la de
otros países europeos ambas están casi
con un pie de salida la misma que la
misión de naciones unidas también en
mali y la eventual récord el rangers
relocalización que está discutiendo
ahora en senegal o en costa de marfil y
en la vecina níger que también son
países que están dentro de la esfera
francesa en el fondo es una cuestión
un sentimiento antifrancés muy
importante claro la expulsión del
embajador francés fue
celebrada con vítores en bamako por por
población civil quiero decir otra
pregunta que surge perdona en este
contexto este tipo de desafíos
logísticos tendría este retiro de
francia
sería
dejar entregado a mali al arsenal y
cadista y el gran problema es que sé que
esta retirada puede ser el caballito de
batalla para el avance de los grupos
yihadistas más al sur digamos a los
países linderos a los países de la costa
del golfo ella es un evento ya es un
fenómeno que se viene produciendo pero
podría recrudecer incluso la llegada
senegal es algo que no se ha visto pero
es un eventual riesgo